This video is sponsored by Brilliant — start
learning today with the link in the description.
Among fast-food chains, Starbucks is unique
in the way that it dominates mainstream culture.
Not only in the language it’s trained us
all to use — Tall, Grande, Venti, etc.,
But also in the scrutiny it receives…
No other cup design can command such controversy,
No other change of store policy gets so much
media attention,
And no other drink has taken on such a life
of its own as the Pumpkin Spice Latte.
Mocked, stereotyped, and yet still highly
adored, Starbucks is known everywhere as the
coffeeshop — almost in a league of its own.
But what you might not know is that, viewed
from a financial perspective, Starbucks is
far more than a seller of expensive drinks
— Starbucks has become a bank.
Whether you know it or not, Starbucks might
already be your bank.
Its customers have lent the company around
$1.6 billion dollars.
In some ways, Starbucks is a technology company,
competing (favorably) with Paypal.
Even some traditional banks are fearful of
what it might do next.
Why?
How did Starbucks, behind all of our backs,
become a bank?
Arguably the first genius idea in Starbuck
history was to carefully craft an experience
— its physical locations would be just as
much an attraction as its coffee.
More than just a restaurant though, each coffeehouse
was designed to act as a “third place”
in our lives — something that would complement
both the rigid, formal setting that is the
workplace and our private homes.
It was well-timed.
As it grew during the 90s and early 2000s,
the number of “shared spaces” which served
a communal, social, inclusive role were in
decline.
Fewer malls, for example, were being built,
and many sat empty or forgotten.
At the same time, more people were becoming
self-employed or had begun working from home,
creating the need for a place with good WiFi,
ample caffeine, and air conditioning.
Tacky as it may sound, Starbucks was also
supposed to be friendly — in a small-town
neighborhood kind of way, encouraging its
employees to get to know regulars, make small
talk, and personalize each cup with its customer’s
name — misspelled as they may be.
Besides these reasons, Starbucks grew thanks
to its great branding, remarkable consistency,
and, yes, arguably, the taste of its coffee.
Most impressively, it expanded very rapidly
without franchising.
The company believed, from the very beginning,
that it needed to exert very tight control
over every process and facet of its presentation.
It was also very good at scouting locations.
So much so that there’s a so-called “Frappuccino
Effect” in real estate — a significant
increase in nearby property prices when a
new location opens.
According to the CEO of Zillow, in the time
a normal home has appreciated by 65%, one
near a Starbucks location will have appreciated
by 96%.
This is likely due in part to the perceived
value of its convenience, but also, in large
part, to Starbucks’ ability to find up-and-coming
neighborhoods before the rest of the market.
The very first location opened in Seattle
in 1971,
There were 84 locations in 1990,
677 in 1995,
The first international, in Japan, during
1996,
3,501 by the turn of the millennium,
And 16,680 in 2008.
At its peak, over 7 new stores were opening
each day.
Around this time, however, Starbucks began
showing signs that it had grown too big, too
fast.
Some in the company attributed these issues
to the wider global recession, but it was
hard to ignore the increasing competition
from McDonald’s, the concern about oversaturation,
and rising customer dissatisfaction.
This culminated when Howard Schultz, a board
member at the time, wrote a brutally honest
internal memo that was somehow leaked to the
press.
The email openly questions its focus on efficiency
and speed over quality, and suggests, politely,
that the company had lost its “magic”.
It was time for a change.
If Starbucks was to continue being, Starbucks,
it needed to do something drastic.
And that, it did.
Schultz, who wrote the leaked memo, was effectively
the founder of modern Starbucks — taking
over the brand in 1982, back when it was just
four little coffeehouses in the Pacific Northwest.
He stepped down in 2000 to devote his time
to international expansion, with a focus on
China.
But in the rocky times of 2008, Schultz was
asked to return to the position of CEO.
He inherited the company’s worst 3-month
performance in its history, and was tasked
with guiding it back to its glory days.
After just one month in his new role, Shultz
made a drastic decision: Things had gotten
so sloppy, he needed to make a big gesture
to reinvigorate the company.
He decided to close every single store for
one day, at an estimated cost of $6 million
dollars in lost profit.
That day, its 135,000 baristas, at the time,
were reminded of the very basics — how to
pour coffee, please customers, and pay attention
to the details.
Later that year, a similar all-hands-on-board
meeting was called at the corporate level.
10,000 of its partners were flown to New Orleans
for an additional $30 million, where they
were updated during a 3-day conference.
And then came the really hard part.
Starbucks closed 600 stores in 2008, followed
by 300 more in 2009.
It did, on the other hand, continue offering
free online college to every employee working
more than 20 hours a week, in partnership
with Arizona State University.
Among quick-serve restaurants, jobs at Starbucks
are highly coveted and see lower than average
turnover.
One of the less high profile changes was an
increasing focus on technology.
This began with the introduction of the Starbucks
Card.
For the uninitiated, the way it works now,
in 2021, is this: Instead of paying with cash
or credit card, you can also add money to
your Starbucks account.
Then, you can pay with the app on your phone,
giving you twice the number of “stars”,
which let you redeem free drinks.
While this may not sound all that revolutionary,
Starbucks is the most popular restaurant rewards
app, allowing it to do what others can’t...
Because of its size and customer loyalty,
people are not afraid to keep decent chunks
of their money in their Starbucks account,
knowing they’ll use it eventually.
41% of U.S. and Canadian users pay with their
Starbucks card.
At the end of 2019, users held a collective
$1.5 billion dollars in balances.
To put this in perspective, 85% of all U.S.
banks have less than $1 billion dollars in
total assets.
Customers will, of course, eventually exchange
this money for coffee, but in the meantime,
unknowingly provide Starbucks with a $1.5
billion dollar loan, at 0% interest.
That’s money Starbucks cou ld simply invest
in the market, earning free money from the
“generosity” of its users, or spend on
building more stores.
Actually, it’s even better than that.
About 10% of this money will be forgotten
or lost and never used — known in the industry
as breakage.
But here’s the thing: Starbucks is not a
bank, legally speaking.
With only a few exceptions, Starbucks balance
cannot be withdrawn for cash, only coffee,
allowing it to bypass financial regulation
and use deposited money however it likes.
It doesn’t, for example, have to keep a
certain amount of cash ready on hand in case
of mass withdrawals.
If it wanted to, Starbucks has all the ingredients
necessary to build a fully-fledged currency
or partner with other brands to create a widely-available
mobile payment system.
Customers already use Starbucks gift cards
as the next best thing to money — it’s
the go-to gift to someone you don’t know
super well but don’t want to give cash.
It’s sorta liquid — not just because it
can be converted to Coffee, but because you
can be reasonably sure anyone will have use
for it, making it an almost universal intermediary.
All this is very scary to regular old banks.
The CEO of South Korea’s third-largest financial
group was quoted calling Starbucks “an unregulated
bank, not a mere coffee company”.
It’s anyone’s guess what Starbucks will
do next, or what its ultimate goals are.
In the meantime, though, no one can say it
hasn’t kept up with the times or managed
an incredible comeback.
As just about every company slowly becomes
a technology company, there’s never been
a better time to learn Computer Science.
Brilliant is a great way to start off 2021
by learning the right way — there are no
grades or homework, just beautiful, interactive
lessons laid out almost like stories.
You learn subjects like programming, statistics,
probability, logic games, and much, much more
— all at your own pace, with no deadlines,
and even, if you like, from your phone.
Use the link in the description to sign up
for free and start learning today.
The first 200 people to use that link will
also get 20% off the annual premium subscription.